philippe petit bonjour bonjour mes
autres caruge vous êtes candidat donc à
l'élection municipale de mars 2020 vous
avez déjà tenté à plusieurs reprises
d'être élu maire de ducos et vous avez
donc décidé de faire une nouvelle
tentative l'année prochaine qu'est ce
qui vous fait espérer philippe petit que
cette fois-là pourrait être la bonne
j'ai toujours coutume de dire qu'il
n'est pas nécessaire d'espérer pour
entreprendre ni de réussir pour
persévérer
je suis un homme d'action et de
conviction il ya un certain nombre de du
coup c'est qu'ils se reconnaissent dans
nos valeurs qui m'ont dit que puisque je
viens de partir à la retraite
eh bien pourquoi je ne mettrais pas
encore plus d'énergie et plus de temps
sur la commune de ducos donc je vous le
dis à l'avance c'est ma dernière
tentative je suis justement l'âge où on
peut regarder d'autres choses dans la
vie mais je suis suffisamment en énergie
en cohérence avec mon raisonnement pour
pouvoir faire ce que les du coup c'est
atteindre un développement de la commune
alors on le rappelle vous avez
l'investiture de lui dire quel serait
votre dossier de préoccupation numéro un
si vous étiez élu maire de ducos en mars
2020 à quoi vous vous attaquez riez
prioritairement prioritairement assainir
les finances et avant une communication
avec le personnel je crois que ça va de
pair parce que il ya eu un petit peu de
gabégie haut niveau il ya eu du laxisme
au niveau de la commune que tout le
monde connaît puisqu'il ya la cour
régionale des comptes a été saisi il ya
de graves dirons-nous infractions qui se
sont produites donc je crois qu'il faut
mettre de l'ordre de la raison de la
guerre met du coeur aussi dans tout ça
puisqu'il faudra concilier ce que je ne
souhaiterais pas fait en tant que maire
s'étale une hausse d'impôts parce que
les gens ont déjà sont déjà très imposé
dans l'espace sud et en particulier à
ducos et deuxièmement le jeu ne
souhaiterait pas licencier du personnel
alors que dans ma vie en tant que chef
d'entreprise j'ai toujours essayé a eu
des difficultés économiques de réduire
la voilure sur des frais généraux sur
des frais de téléphone sur des frais de
voiture sur un certain nombre de primes
vedette indus qui peuvent à mon avis
être reversé lors je m'en sens qu'on est
à licencier comme le demande la cour
régionale des comptes
pour la ville du cos et ses habitants
philippe petit selon vous qu'est-ce qui
va se jouer de fondamental dans près de
cinq mois un maintenant sachant que le
maire en place a décidé de ne pas se
représenter
écoutez la main timide amant et un
déperdition à démographie puisque les
gens s'en vont donc il faut rendre le
territoire attractif du cos a la chance
d'être à la fois rurale parce qu'il ya
quand même de grande mobilité manière il
ya de la can aussi de la petite
agriculture à la fois proche de
l'aéroport donc une lieu qui peut être
très attractif pour le touriste de
passage pour tous les hommes d'affaires
est à la fois à des espaces réduits
parce que c'est pas une grande commune
en surface qui peuvent permettre le
bien-être pouvoir relier tout ça en gros
ce que je vous décris sait qu'il faudra
un hôtel au centre ville et refaire tout
le centre ville autour de cette idée de
dynamisation comme dit un hôtel c'est un
hôtel hôtel de ville ou telle lampe
annoncé mardi en des touristes notre
ciel vous recevoir les touristes ne
voulait pas trop l'hôtel de ville en
améliorant en discuter en deux c'est à
dire redynamiser le centre du mot dans
l'espace culturel grâce à déjà
certainement un hôtel mais deuxièmement
et surtout des spectacles musicaux sur
la base de ce spectacle son et lumière
comme on a pu faire au puy-du-fou
philippe de villiers c'est-à-dire fait
que ça soit une commune culturel grâce à
son nom de l' usine et des étages où il
y avait eu à l'époque l'assassinât
plongeant dans rocket effet une scène de
vie ou que du coup ça le patrimoine
culturel ou que les touristes viennent
vont donc sacrés de la restauration il
ya un certain nombre de modifications
que j'ai en tête
donc je pense qu'à partir de là du
cospar a redécollé être attractif et
aider la martinique à son développement
philippe petit merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
merci